I pledge to every citizen of our land
that I will be President for all
Americans and this is so important to me
Donald Trump won the u.s. presidential
election Tuesday night and late-night TV
hosts had a lot to say about it like
Seth Meyers who reflected on the fact we
still have yet to see a female president
that does mean that someone's daughter
is out there right now who will one day
have that title even got a bit
teary-eyed whoever you are I hope I live
to see your inauguration and I hope my
mom does too she was really excited
yesterday and I was really sad for her
Conan O'Brien expressed how thankful he
is for the right to vote everybody
should feel grateful that we get to vote
and if we don't get our way we have the
chance to try again Jimmy Fallon took a
moment to offer a message of positivity
this guy came up to me and he said hey
we're gonna need some laughs tonight and
that's what we do my job is to come out
of here every night and try to make you
laugh and take your mind off of things
for a while while Stephen Colbert
encouraged voters to never give up don't
stop
speaking up don't stop speaking your
mind don't ever be cowed by what happens
in the next four years and british-born
James Corden shared why he loves living
in the USA it's almost two years ago to
the day when a mere my wife told my son
that we were gonna be moving to America
and and he looked at us I'll never
forget it when daddy that's great and he
was three and a half but somehow he knew
intrinsically that this was a fantastic
place to live
Jimmy Kimmel kept the mood light on his
show last night Donald Trump reached out
and grabbed America by the Virginia to
somehow
President of the United States Robert
DeNiro who previously released a video
condemning Trump was a guest on the
program are you still gonna punch Donald
Trump in the face I can't do that now
and I just have to see we have to see
how what he's gonna do and how he's
really gonna follow through on certain
things over on watch what happens live
scandal star Tony Goldwyn expressed his
disappointment in Clinton's loss you
were at the Javits Center last night
waiting for Hillary must have been not
that fun turned out not to be so much
fun but did it miss the opportunity to
spread a little humor the for reality TV
mogul as president of the United States
it really should have been Andy Cohen
you